الطريقة الوحيدة التي سيعمل بها اللقاح
فعليًا على إنهاء الوباء
هي بالطبع إذا أخذ الناس اللقاح إذا تم
تطعيمهم وتقول الإدارة القادمة
إنها ستعمل
على تعزيز الثقة في
سلامة اللقطة
، هل أنت واثق من أنه إذا ومتى
أعطت إدارة الغذاء والدواء هذه
الموافقة ، فستكون آمنة وفعالة
، وسوف
تأخذها بالطبع ، وسأفعل أنك تخطط للحصول على
التطعيم قبل
يوم التنصيب ، وسوف تفعل ذلك
علنًا بالطريقة التي اقترحها الرئيسان أوباما
بوش وكلينتون أنهما
مستعدان  سأكون سعيدًا للقيام بذلك
بمجرد إعلان أنه آمن ، وبعد ذلك
أعتقد أن
باراك قال بمجرد أن قال فوسي أنه من الواضح
أن هذا هو الإجراء الخاص بي ،
ومن الواضح أننا نأخذه ومن
المهم التواصل مع الأمريكيين
، فمن الآمن القيام بذلك
لذلك بموافقته على أخذ هذا اللقاح
علنًا ،
أخذ الرئيس المنتخب وآخرون
صفحة من كتاب إلفيس
بريسلي لأنه في عام 1956 أخذ
لقاح شلل الأطفال
خلف الكواليس في إد سوليفان  أظهر لتشجيع
المراهقين على التطعيم ، هل ينجح ذلك؟
وجود شخص مشهور أو رئيس في هذه
الحالة يأخذ لقاحًا أمام
الجمهور
عندما أخذ إلفيس بريسلي لقاح شلل الأطفال
في إد سوليفان ، أظهر
الناس اصطفوا للحصول على لقاح شلل الأطفال
كما كان  أحدث هواتف iPhone
التي كانوا سعداء للقيام بذلك ، وكانوا
سعداء بالانتظار وقد تم إلهامهم
لأننا بحاجة إلى قادة ملهمين لمساعدتنا في
بناء الثقة
وكل واحد منا مستوحى من طرق مختلفة.
عائلة
بعضنا يسحق المشاهير
ماثيو ماكونهي هو لي بريانا وأنا
أعلم أنك حصلت على واحدة أيضًا ،
لذا دعونا جميعًا نتكئ ونطلب من
شركائنا المشاهير
قادة مجتمعنا لمساعدتنا في
بناء ثقة المجتمع هذه ولكن دعونا أيضًا لا
ننسى المشاهير المحليين لك  يجب أن
تتكئ الآن على طبيبك المحلي ،
اتصل بطبيبك.
مناقشة اللقاح أين
ومتى وكيف يمكنك أن تبدأ تلك
المحادثة الآن
مع طبيبك